nous avons choisi de ne rien changer
pour celles qui sont aujourd'hui à moins
de 17 ans de leur retraite
c'est à dire pour le régime général les
personnes nées avant 1975 qui auront
plus de 50 ans en 2025
cela veut dire que toutes les personnes
qui se projette déjà dans leur retraite
qu'ils ont préparés qu'ils l'ont
planifié dans l'ancien système ne seront
pas concernés par le système universel
comme les retraités actuels eux mêmes
cela va sans dire mais faut toujours le
rappeler
quant aux personnes qui rejoignent le
nouveau régime je voudrais les rassurer
la transition sera très progressive
toute la partie de carrière effectuée
jusqu'à 2025 donnera lieu à une retraite
calculée sur les anciennes règles
seuls les années travaillées à partir de
2025 seront régies par le système
universel
la première génération concernée la
génération 1975 qui prendra sa retraite
vers 2030 cette aura donc encore 70% de
sa retraite calculée selon l'ancien
système
vous verrez j'en prends le pari que
beaucoup qui verront les avantages du
nouveau système trouveront que cela ne
va pas assez vite